the Associated Press has a major story
this morning breaking saying that there
were six key days when this outbreak
started where top Chinese officials kept
it quiet they knew that this was all
developing they essentially covered it
up
they let millions of people travel
around the Lunar New Year and here we
are now with thousands of Americans who
have died our entire economy upended
what do you plan to do what can you do
in the days ahead to hold China
accountable well first let me speak to
what DoD is doing here in the United
States and I would say that from the
beginning going back to late January DoD
has been all in when it comes to
protecting the American people and we've
been consistently ahead of the curve
when we have deployed equipment or
troops and doctors and nurses to
American cities so we've been all in we
continue to do that I'm very proud of
the 50,000 plus service members around
the country and abroad who are actually
providing the support to our to our
great country
with regard to with regard to China and
the information coming out of there as
many of us have spoken from folks across
the political spectrum clearly the
Chinese could have been more transparent
earlier and shared much more the data we
would had a better understanding of this
virus and then how to deal with it and I
think we you know even today we see them
withholding information and so I think
we need to we need to do more and
continue to press them to Sheriff the
way out of this the way the tort of
resolution to get back to normal or
near-normal
is that we all cooperate all nations
around the world cooperate to understand
this virus and to get it under control
and we're just simply not seeing what we
need to see from China right now and
following up on that where are you then
in terms of the military in this
investigation that general Milley was
referring to about getting the bottom he
believes it was natural but they were
still intrigued out there and so far
he's been saying we don't know for sure
where this started when will we be able
to conclusively determine where are we
in this investigation as to whether it
came from that lab or not well we do
know it started in Wuhan China and I
won't speak to intelligence reporting
beyond that but I would say that most
people believe that was it they began
naturally it was organic if you will I
think in due course once we get through
the pandemic wound right now there'll be
time to look back and really ascertain
what happened and to make sure we have a
better understanding so we can prevent
this in
future